bonsoir Monsieur Fillon alors
parlez-nous un peu de jesoft si je vous
demandais de décrire ça vous êtes
habitué là mais en quelques mots ouais
ben dis ça on est une entreprise
technologique on bâti des logiciels pour
entreprises qui vise à améliorer
l'expérience employée au travail on
s'intéresse à l'engagement au travail on
s'intéresse à la mise en place des
objectifs l'accueil intégration
on s'intéresse au développement des
compétences la formation des employés
l'optimisation de la plateforme
numérique en philosexify de Microsoft
donc on a disons une variété de produits
logiciels qui pour nous s’inscrit
vraiment dans le contexte de
l'expérience employée au travail 125
millions de la Caisse de dépôt pour
faire quoi
juste pour donner un peu un historique
d'entreprise pour nous on a fondé
l'entreprise en 2006 on a autofinancé
l'entreprise depuis ça faisait 17 ans
qu'on avait en fait on a commencé
l'entreprise comme entreprise de service
on a réussi avec les revenus à pouvoir
financer nos produits et les produits
ont eu du succès et
récemment il y a quelques mois on a fait
une première acquisition d'une
entreprise de Québec
la gestion de l'apprentissage en
entreprise et pour nous c'était vraiment
une première de faire une acquisition
parce que depuis 17 ans c'était nous qui
bâtissait tous nos produits et rendu à
la tête que jesoft a aujourd'hui pour
rester compétitif dans le marché pour
continuer d'amener de la valeur à nos
clients faire des acquisitions devient
un levier stratégique qui est important
pour nous mais on a aussi la chance
d'être une entreprise qui a une grande
habileté à bâtir nos propres produits
fac c'est l'idée c'est de marier les
deux oui et donc la Caisse de dépôt va
vous aider dans le fond à faire des
acquisitions les acquisitions à
l'international oui ben on s'intéresse
on regarde beaucoup au Canada aux
États-Unis en Europe aussi
mais oui on arrive vraiment on est dans
un contexte où est-ce que l'entreprise
financièrement va très bien et
de financement là va vraiment nous aider
à aller chercher dénicher des belles
entreprises qui existent
Québec de la caisse de dépôts il disait
ça dans la presse cette semaine on est
présent dans 160 dans 70 pays on a des
possibilités grâce à notre réseau de
5000 personnes donc la caisse vous offre
vous ouvre les portes du monde
définitivement les portes du monde et
des dans des dans des industries qu'on
est peut-être pas autant présent
aujourd'hui mais additionnons ça avec
jesof qui est aussi dans plus de 17000
entreprises aujourd'hui dans une
centaine de pays donc on a on a disons
accès au monde entier ensemble et votre
entreprise vraiment exploser je dirais
durant durant la pandémie dans les
dernières années vous avez presque
doubler votre nombre d'employés en un an
et demi votre chiffre d'affaires qui a
cru de 30% on parle d'un chiffre
d'affaires de 100 millions maintenant
100 millions de dollars américains c'est
quand même pas rien qu'est-ce qui
explique le succès des dernières années
comment vous l'expliquer
ah c'est c'est l'addition de plein de
choses puis oui le 100 millions de
revenus c'est comme juste le dire c'est
comme spécial puis ça fait nous
une entreprise je crois assez unique
dans notre dans notre contexte surtout
qu'on s'est autofinancé pour se rendre
jusque-là mais
on a gardé ça simple je pense qu'on a
compris très tôt dans l'histoire de
jesof qu'on était oui une entreprise
technologique mais avant tout une
entreprise humaine donc on est une
entreprise créative ça se passe entre
les deux oreilles de chaque personne et
pour réussir à aller chercher le
meilleur de chaque personne mais il faut
sucer les conditions pour ça donc très
tôt de vie ça crée un environnement qui
je crois avaient les conditions de créer
ce qu'on a réussi à faire et c'est sûr
que il y a sûrement eu un peu de chance
des bonnes idées à l'exécution était là
et on est là aujourd'hui et 100 millions
de revenus 125 millions qui vient de la
caisse est-ce que c'est encore possible
de garder ça simple
ben oui ben je l'espère mais bon on est
ça dépend de vous ça dépend des gens
autour de vous je pense que ce qui est
important dans ce dire là c'est qu'on on
est capable de garder un peu la
philosophie de gisoft la case de dépôt
comme nous avoir à long terme puis je
pense que c'est le concert et
17 ans pour se rendre où est-ce qu'on
est aujourd'hui et et on a envie d'être
là encore dans 15 20 25 ans et
sachant qu'on a un peu cet espace mental
là pour continuer d'opérer de l'histoire
comment le si bien fait depuis 17 ans
mais pour moi ça me dit qu'on a des
chances de
rester qui on est d'avoir du succès dans
le futur excellent merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu nous voir ce soir
félicitations et bonne chance pour la
suite merci beaucoup merci bien pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]